good morning hick it's Tuesday after all
the excitement this weekend I feel like
we could use a little peace and quiet so
let's just make some pottery today
those birds are some good paid actors by
the way please don't correct my Pottery
technique I'm not trying to be good at
Pottery I'm trying to distract myself
from all the uh gestures broadly
okay so I'm centering the clay here I'm
making these little closed forms I call
secret Keepers the idea is that you
whisper something that's difficult or
painful or traumatic or whatever into
the little holes at the bottom of the
secret keeper and then the secret kinda
lives inside the form instead of having
to live inside your brain I want them to
be a little wonky so absolutely
centering the clay on the wheel is not
like Mission critical but with Pottery
as with brains centering is helpful so
as of recording this the 16th annual
project for awesome has raised just over
three million dollars for charity you
can still donate at
projectforawesome.com donate until the
end of the day I don't know what to say
about the p4a except that every year it
is awesome in the classical sense of the
word overwhelming intimidating thrilling
and above all beautiful all weekend long
I kept thinking how lucky we are Hank to
still be able to do this to still feel
the warmth and the light of this
community it's just incredible so now
that I've got the clay centered enough
for my party I just start to press down
in the middle and it's sort of naturally
forms sides now you're starting to work
with a cylinder I'm going to very
inefficiently and inelegantly pull the
sides of the cylinder up now so that the
Secret Keeper can have some height to it
the thing about making Pottery on a
wheel is that the wheel actually does
almost all of the work Wheels by the way
were not initially invented for
transport or whatever they were invented
for pottery and when I throw pots like
this one I often feel as if I'm doing
something ancient but in fact it's not
that ancient like both eating bread and
drinking beer are older than wheels and
indeed older than wheel thrown Pottery I
think my favorite part of the project
for awesome this year was at the very
end when our families were on the stream
and everyone was celebrating together in
the chat got together and wrote we're
here because we're here because we're
here because we're here
it was just so lovely a kind of written
Global chorus the p4a just it's just the
best tank it reminds me that hope is the
correct response to Consciousness now
there's a word for what I'm doing right
now with the clay but I kind of forget
what it is basically I'm trying to coax
the walls of my vessel toward each other
using very light pressure from my palms
and my fingers if before I was bringing
the clay up now I'm trying to bring it
in and this is the place where it can
and often does all fall apart I have to
be everything my highly distracted
internet-based brain does not want me to
be attentive steady patient it's
something close to meditation once I've
got the form closed at last then it's
happy happy fun time I'm gonna play with
a tool here mostly just for Giggles but
also because I do enjoy a spiral and
this lets me carve little spirals into
the clay sometimes I end up wanting to
keep them other times I end up mostly
smoothing them over but even when you
can't see the spiral you can sometimes
feel it in your hand when you hold the
secret keeper and I like how some things
that cannot be seen are nonetheless felt
and then once it's done I take it off
the wheel and bring it over to dry with
its friends I used to think art had to
be great to be worthwhile now I only
think it has to be to be worthwhile
Hank thanks for 16 amazing piferas I'll
see you on Friday